Okay.
Schönen guten Abend, mein Name ist Ucak.
Ich bin auf der Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das
Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Danke, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Melanie Schreiber.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, M-I-R-A-N-I Melanie.
Ja.
C-H-R-E-I-B-E-R.
Okay.
Wie schreiben, ja?
Ja, Schreiber R.
Okay.
Frau Schreiber, wie alt sind Sie?
47 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
7. Oktober 1978.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 69.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zuzeit?
Ich bin 58 Kilogramm, Doktor.
Danke für die Informationen, Frau Schreiber.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit gestern habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen lokalisiert?
Ich meine Oberbauch, Unterbauch.
Die Schmerzen haben zunächst um den Nabel herum begonnen
und sind heute Morgen in den rechten Unterbauch gewandert.
Okay.
Frau Schreiber, können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Also sind Sie eher druckend, stechend, dumpf?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind dumpf und steckend.
Dumpf und steckend.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten.
Okay.
Haben sich die Schmerzen im Verlauf der Zeit verändert?
Ich meine, schlimmer geworden oder besser geworden?
Die Schmerzen sind immer schlimmer geworden.
Am Anfang waren die Schmerzen bei 1.
Aber heute liegen sie bei 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Okay.
Frau Schreiber, soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmitte geben
oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ein anderes Gespräch dauert ca. 20 Minuten.
Ich kann warten, Doktor.
Okay, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid, wenn Sie ein Medikament benötigen.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich werde mich beeilen.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden sind.
Und gibt es eine bestimmte Faktoren?
Also ich meine eine bestimmte Körperhaltung oder Besten?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor. Nein.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Das ist zum ersten Mal.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ich habe keine Medikamente eingenommen, Doktor.
Okay. Sind Sie schon wegen dieser Schmerzen beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich habe nicht beim anderen Arzt gewesen, nein.
Okay. Frau Schreiber, haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrost oder Nachtschwass?
Ja, ich habe stark geschwitzt und möglicherweise Fieber, aber ich habe keine Temperatur gemessen.
Okay. Schüterfrost, Nachtschwass. Also Sie haben eine Schweißausbrüche, ich glaube.
Ja, ja.
Aber besonders haben Sie eine Nachtschwass?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Husten?
Ich habe diese Beschwerden nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay. Frau Schreiber, sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft.
Okay. Ist Ihnen übel oder musst du sie erbrechen?
Ich habe keine Übelkeit unter Erbrechen, Doktor.
Das freut mich. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Wegen dieser Schmerzen habe ich Appetitlosigkeit.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich ab oder zugenommen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt. Ich denke, ich bin immer gleichgewischt.
Okay, super. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ich habe keine Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang.
Okay, das freut mich. Frau Schreiber, schlafen Sie gut?
Wegen dieser Schmerzen seit gestern schlafe ich nicht gut, Doktor.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Beide.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten oder Covid-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Okay. Frau Schreiber, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich habe eine Schilddrüsenfunktion, Unterfunktion.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter diesen Problemen?
Seit 10 Jahren.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme 100 Mikrogramm Ethyroxin ein. Einmal täglich abends.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas?
Vor 13 Jahren hatte ich einen Skiunfall. Damals wurde nur ein Röntgen mitgemacht.
Ich bleibe ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus für Beobachtung.
Aber bei mir wurde keine Operation durchgeführt.
Okay. Und war alles in Ordnung?
Nicht mit Medikation behandelt, ja.
Ich weiß welche Medikation. Ich weiß nicht.
Gab es eine Verletzung, zum Beispiel einen Bruch oder Torsion?
Mein Arzt hat mir nicht gesagt, wie ich habe. Aber ich denke, gibt es eine Möglichkeit für eine Torsion?
Okay. Frau Schreiber, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Schmidt.
Okay. Frau Schreiber, ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas? Irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Vor drei Monaten wurde mir ein Depot im Nackenbereich operiert.
Okay. Ja, das war es?
Im Jahr 2013 hatte ich Krampaden im Beidenbeinen.
Und bei mir wurde eine Laserbehandlungtherapie durchgeführt.
Okay. Alles klar. Sonst noch irgendwelche Erkrankungen oder Operationen?
Ja, ich leide außerdem unter chronischen Belangen. Wogegen ich Kräuter trinke.
Okay. Alles klar.
Frau Schreiber?
Entschuldigung, Doktor. Ich habe seit sehr langer Zeit nicht mehr Müdigkeit.
Dafür nehme ich Eisenpapel, die ich aus der Drogerie gekauft habe.
Ohne russische Sprache. Ist das falsch oder richtig, Doktor?
Also, Frau Schreiber, die Einnahme von Medikamenten ohne ärztlichen Rat kann für Sie gefährlich sein.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, Ihren Hausarzt regelmäßig zu besuchen. Ja, für Ihre Beschwerden. Okay?
Okay.
Okay. Frau Schreiber, besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, natürlich. Ich gehe mindestens drei Monate bei Ihrem Frauenarzt.
Ist alles in Ordnung?
Ja, ja. Alles ist in Ordnung.
Okay. Wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Vor 14 Tagen.
Okay. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf irgendwelche anderen Medikamente, außer genannten, ein?
Ja, ich habe auch Schlachttrünge sehr lange Zeit. Ich habe fast mit Kraut betrieben.
Okay. Alles klar.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen, Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich bin allergisch gegen Nickel und habe eine Sonnenallergie.
Okay. Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Das ist, das äußert sich mit Ukrains und Eczem.
Meinen Sie Nickel oder?
Ja, Nickel und Sonnenallergie.
Ähnlich, ja?
Ja, ähnlich, ja.
Okay. Alles klar. Frau Schreiber, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche, ja.
Seit wann und wie viel rauchen Sie?
Seit 20 Jahren rauche ich halb Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Okay. Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ich trinke gelegentlich ein Glas Wein am Wochenende oder einen Verein oder treffe mit meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Verstehe. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich probiere nicht Drogen, Doktor, nein.
Das freut mich. Frau Schreiber, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall, Bluthochdruck?
Ja, mein Vater hatte Bluthochdruck, ja. Meine Mutter ist gynäkologisch gesund und meine Schwester hatte ein Uteresium.
Das war drei Monate Uteresium.
Okay. Und wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, ist Ihre Mutter gesund, ja?
Ja, meine Mutter ist gesund, ja.
Okay, Gott sei Dank. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin getrennt. Ich bin verheiratet, aber getrennt.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Ist Ihre Tochter gesund?
Ja, sie ist gesund, ja.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Mit meiner Tochter.
Okay. Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Verkäuferin in einem Spielwarengeschäft.
Spielzeuggeschäft, ja?
Ja, ja.
Okay. Frau Schravi, ich möchte eine Frage über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden stellen.
Also, haben Sie eine Hautfarbeveränderung bemerkt? Ich meine Gelbsucht oder ... ja?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Okay. Das waren meine Fragen. Haben Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, Doktor. Was habe ich? Ich habe viel Angst. Meine Tochter ist letztes Jahr an Mama-Krebs gestorben.
Ich habe Krebs, oder?
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören, Frau Schreiber. Also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Aufgrund Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden ist der Krebs unwahrscheinlich.
Aber ich muss zuerst Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihren Brut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Wie zum Beispiel Ultraschall-Untersuchung.
Was ist Ultraschall?
Ja, das ist eine Untersuchung-Methode, Frau Schreiber. Damit können wir Ihre inneren Organe sehen.
Das ist sowohl schmerzfrei als auch schrallenfrei.
Okay.
Ja.
Es ist nicht gefährlich, unsere meine Körper. Richtig?
Ja, Sie haben recht. Es gibt kein Risiko.
Okay.
Sobald die Allergie ...
Okay. Dauert es sehr lange, oder?
Bitte schön.
Dauert es sehr lange, oder?
Nein, diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20 Minuten, Frau Schreiber.
Oh, gut.
Ja? Okay.
Also, Frau Schreiber, ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben.
Okay.
Damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können.
Aber wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Ich vermute, dass Sie eine Blutdarmentzündung haben.
Ja?
Also, könnte es sein, dass Sie operiert werden müssen.
Aber wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie sind jetzt bei uns in guten Händen und wir haben viele Erfahrungen über diese Erkrankung.
Okay. Darf ich eine Frage stellen, Doktor?
Ja, gerne.
Ich habe keine viel Geld. Bescheid ich diese Sonographie? Ich habe gesetzliche Versicherung.
Ja?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Also, alle Untersuchungen sind kostenlos, Frau Schreiber.
Oh, gut. Danke schön.
Ja, gerne. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz und warten Sie mal. Ich bin gleich wieder da. Okay?
Okay. Ich warte auf Sie, Doktor. Danke schön.
Ja, gerne. Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über Sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön. Frau Melanie Schreiber ist 47 Jahre alt, 1,69 Meter groß und 58 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Schreiber stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern bestehender Abdominalschmerzen vor.
Der Patientin zufolge sah in die Schmerzen am Anfang an periomikale Regionen aufgetreten
und mit der Zeit in den rechten Unterbauch gewandert. Die Schmerzen seien dumpf und stechend.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzskala am Anfang 1 von 10 und momentan 7 von 10 bewertet.
Die Patienten haben keine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen.
Die Patienten berichteten über Fieber, Pyrexie und Hyperhidrose.
Aber die Patienten haben ihr Fieber nicht gemessen.
Die Fragen nach Hautfarbeveränderungen, Dyspnoe, Trussis, Schütterfrost und nächtliche Hyperhidrose wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Schmerzbedingte Appetenz, Schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Einschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen.
Sie seien vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
Und die Patienten besuchten ihren Hausarzt regelmäßig alle drei Monate.
Ihre letzte Periode war vor zwei Wochen.
Anfroerkrankungen nannte sie seit 10 Jahren bestehende Hypothyriose.
Sie nehme dagegen L-Tiroxin 100 mg abends ein.
Vor 13 Jahren hatte sie einen Skiunfall und sie wurde im Krankenhaus 24 Stunden beobachtet.
Sie leide an chronischem Meteorismus und chronischer Fatigue.
Die Patienten trinken gegen Meteorismus Kräuter Tee und sie nehmen Eisentabletten ein ohne ärztlichen Rat.
Sie haben Allergie gegen Nickel und sie haben auch eine Sonnenallergie, die sich durch Pruritus und Eczem äußern.
Sie sind Raucherin und sie rauchen 10 Zigaretten täglich seit 20 Jahren.
Sie trinken gelegentlich ein Glas Wein am Wochenende und der Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass der Vater an arterieller Hypertonie leide und die Mutter sei gesund.
Sie hat eine Schwester und ihre Schwester hatte eine Operation vor drei Monaten wegen einer Uterus-Mioma.
Die Patientin sei getrennt, habe eine gesunde Tochter und sie wohne mit ihrer Tochter zusammen.
Sie sei Verkäuferin von Beruf in einem Spielzeuggeschäft.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Appendicitis aus, da die Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin leidet unter Abdominal Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen seien am Anfang in der periomikalen Region aufgetreten und mit der Zeit in den rechten Unterbauch gewandert.
Sie haben Fieber und Hyperhydrose.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Appendicitis.
Als die Diagnosen kommen, die Urolithiasis, Ovarian Distortion, Extrauterin Graviditerit, Koloncarcinom in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei der Patientin die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Druckschmerzen, Loslassschmerzen und Abwehrspannung, Hautfarbeveränderungen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Nierenwerte, Leberwerte und Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Abdominalsynographie durchführen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine CT des Abdomens mit Kontrastmittel durchführen, um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen und der Patientin einen Venosanzugang legen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten, der Patientin, Analytika, Antipyretika, Spasmolytika verabreichen.
Nahrungskarenz ist auch sehr wichtig bei den Patienten. Danach würde ich ein chirurgisches Konsil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise verstanden sind, werde ich mit den geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben gesagt, ich würde eine Abenduktion durchführen. Welche Operation empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Wenn es eine Komplikation wie z.B. Tertiforation, Abscess oder Fisten gibt, würde ich den Patienten eine offene Operation empfehlen.
Ansonsten würde ich eine laparoscopische Operation empfehlen.
Können Sie uns die laparoscopische Abenduktion aufklären?
Ja, ich werde gerne Sie über die laparoscopische Abenduktion aufklären.
Um diese Operation durchzuführen, soll der Patient nüchtern sein.
Wie viele Stunden soll der Patient nüchtern sein?
Minimal 8 Stunden.
Aber diese Operation ist Notfall?
Ja, das ist eine Notfallsituation. Deswegen sollen wir die Patienten eine Operation durchführen.
So schnell wie möglich. Sollen wir eine Operation durchführen.
Ich glaube wir sprechen über diese Patienten. Ich werde über diese Patienten aufklären.
Die Patienten erhalten eine Vollnarkose vor der Operation.
Zuerst desinfizieren wir die Operationstelle.
Dann machen wir eine Hautschneid am Rand des Nabels, um eine optische Instrumente einzuführen.
Danach machen wir zwei weitere kleine Hautschneid, um die anderen Operationinstrumente einzuführen.
Danach lokalisieren wir den Blinddarm und entfernen ihn mit einem Klammergerät.
Danach legen wir eine Drainage um die Wundflüssigkeiten und Nachblutungen einzuleiten und zu kontrollieren.
Dann vernehmen wir die Wunde.
Diese Operation dauert ca. eine Stunde.
Wenn alles gut läuft, sollen die Patienten 3-5 Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Nach der Entlassung sollen die Patienten vermeiden von schwierigen Bewegungen.
Es gibt einige Komplikationen bei diesen Operationen, wie z.B. Nachblutungen und Infektionen.
Nach der Entlassung sollen die Patienten ins Krankenhaus kommen und zu kontrollieren.
Welche Erfindung oder Ergebnisse erwarten Sie bei der Obdomanzonographie?
Wir können eine Verdickung an der Blinddarm feststellen.
Auch freie Flüssigkeit können wir bei der Untersuchung feststellen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie vermuten als Differentialdiagnose ein paar Krankheiten.
Wie können wir andere Krankheiten ausschließen?
Als Differentialdiagnose kommen Overall Distortionen, können wir eine Doppelultrasonographie durchführen.
Um die extrauterin Gravität auszuschließen, können wir BTHCG-Werte bestimmen.
Auch Urolithiasis kommt als Differentialdiagnose. Um eine Urolithiasis auszuschließen, können wir eine Bröntgenaufnahme durchführen oder eine Obdomanzonographie.
Ist es möglich, Morbus Crohn oder Qualitiv-Syphsereza?
Die Patienten leiden unter keine verdammt starken Probleme wie Durchfall oder Obst.
Aber Radsdarm-Syndrom ist eine Differentialdiagnose.
Deswegen würden Sie in diesem Fall eine Koloskopie durchführen?
Momentan können wir keine Koloskopie durchführen.
Es gibt eine Kontraindikation bei diesem akuten Fall. Aber nach der Therapie können wir eine Koloskopie durchführen, um die mögliche Pathologie zu beurteilen.
Herr Kollegen, können Sie uns auch eine Obdomanzonographie aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über die Obdomanzonographie aufklären.
Die Obdomanzonographie gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung ist sowohl schmerzfrei als auch strahlenfrei.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Blutungen, Tumore und andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Wir sollen vorher die zu untersuchenden Körperregionen, hier den Bauch, mit einem Gel einschmieren, damit der Schallkopf fehlerfrei arbeitet.
Die Ultraschallwellen machen die inneren Organe sichtbar und wir können die inneren Organe auf einem Monitor sehen.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20 Minuten. Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontraindikationen.
Es gibt auch keine Einschränkungen nach der Untersuchung.
Der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Gibt es eine Alternative Methode der Obdomanzonographie?
Ja, gegebenenfalls können wir eine CT des Obdomens durchführen mit Kontrastmeter, besonders bei diesem Fall.
Wir können diese Untersuchung bei unklaren Ultrasonographiebefunden machen.
Was behalten Sie bei der Perspiration?
Bei der Perspiration achte ich darauf, ob McBurnie-Zeichen vorhanden ist.
Das ist eine Druckschmerzen in dem rechten Unterbauch zwischen Nabel und Spina Iliaca anterior superior.
Loslassschmerzen und Abwehrspannung sind sehr wichtig, um eine Peritonitis zu beurteilen.
Würden Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung den meisten Bereich untersuchen?
Ja, das ist auch sehr wichtig.
In den rechten Unterbauchschmerzen können wir auch eine Incarcerative Herni feststellen.
Deswegen sollen wir diesen Bereich auch untersuchen.
Was behalten Sie bei der Leistung?
Wir sollen eine Beule im Leistungsbereich untersuchen.
Wir können diese Beule untersuchen, ob sie zurückdrückbar ist.
Und wir untersuchen während der körperlichen Untersuchung vergrößerte Liefknoten?
Ja, das ist auch sehr wichtig.
Wir sollen die vergrößerten Liefknoten genau untersuchen, um die möglichen Maligen, Karsinoma oder Metastasen zu beurteilen.
Vielen Dank Herr Kollege. Bitte gehen Sie auf unser Info-Desk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihr Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank Herr Oberarzt. Sie sind sehr nett. Das war sehr schön und ein angenehmer Gespräch bei mir. Danke.